these are just some of the coffins
containing the bodies of the illegal
immigrants who drowned after trying to
reach the island of lampedusa at the
invitation of the head of the italian
government in ricoletta the president of
the commission finally made the journey
to take stock of the tragedy faced with
a recent tragedy and the high influx of
refugees the italian authorities have
called for solidarity from the eu this
tragedy of today
shows us that it's indispensable to step
up
our efforts and that is the message that
i will also convey to the european
council to the heads of state and
government however this is not a new
issue for several months the european
parliament has been working on the
implementation of eurosur an information
exchange system set up to deal with the
issues of illegal
kind of information will be shared first
of all the illegal movements of people
along the border that will be shared
immediately with all the member states
and why is that important because in
europe itself
we have in europe without borders you
can travel freely from france to germany
and all the way around so the weakest
link in the external border affects all
the member states however usa's critics
argue that it merely enforces the whole
idea of a european fortress i think the
safety of borders that is currently
missing is the safety of people who are
trying to reach the european union who
are looking for protection here those
people are not at all protected for the
moment they have to take very risky
journeys over land oversea because we've
been closing off the borders
continuously over the last years the
european external border surveillance
system or euroce will be operational
from december 2013.
since 2009 it's estimated that more than
4 000 illegal migrants have died in the
mediterranean in their attempt to reach
european shores